Hello, my name is
Gonzalo Tazu, and
today we will talk
about the neuroanatomy
of the visual
system, including eye
functional anatomy
and vision pathways.
So students
should be able to
describe the
neural, muscular
and vascular
anatomy of the eye.
You should also be
able to describe
the neural processing
within the eye.
You should be able
to take visual
pathways underlying
visual perception,
and you should
be able to relate
visual deficits to
dysfunctions to specific
portions of the
visual pathway.
Let's start with the eye.
So the eye has
three concentric
tissue layers and a lens.
So the first layer
is the sclera.
So in front of the
pupil, this first
layer is transparent,
so the light can go
through it. And on
the other part, it's
not transparent,
it's called sclera.
Now the second layer
is the choroid.
The choroid
includes a vascular
layer, the ciliary
body, and the iris.
And the third layer of
the eye is the retina.
The retina is
divided in two parts.
There is a retinal
pigment epithelium, which
in this section we can
see it around here,
which contains the
blood supply to the
neural retina. where
the photoreceptors are
located here now
the space around the
pupil is divided in
two spaces there's the
anterior chamber and
the posterior chamber
the anterior chamber
is the space from
the iris to the cornea
and the posterior
chamber is from the
iris to the lens.
So the anterior
and posterior
chambers are filled
with acus humus.
Also, it's important
to remember that in
looking at the retina,
that the retinal pigment
epithelium is where
the blood supply is,
Where the neural retinates
separate from the
retinal pigment epithelium,
the blood supply
to the nerve cells
will be compromised,
resulting in neural death
and blindness. And this
condition is called
retinal detachment. so
the eye so this is
an optic element so
the shape of the eye
is very important
to have proper
proper focusing
of light so the
way so contrary
to the cameras
built by humans
which are rigid the
eye shape is maintained
due to the intraocular
pressure so
So, here, the ciliary
body is going to
be secreting the
aqueous humor into
the posterior chamber,
which can be seen
here. This is the
posterior chamber.
And this aqueous
humor flows from the
posterior chamber into
the anterior chamber.
The trabecular meshwork,
which is similar
to the arachnoid
granulations at the
iridocorneal angle,
are responsible
for the drainage of
this aqueous humor.
So the endothelium
-lined scleral
venous sinus,
which is also
called the
canal of Schlem,
communicates
directly with the
venous drainage
of the eye.
So now on the other
part of the eye, close
to the retina here,
the vitreous humor
is filled with a
gelatinous material, so
pressure on the anterior
eye is transmitted
to the rest of the
eye. So the pressure
is controlled here
and is applied here.
So the excessive
intraocular pressure is
detrimental and that
condition is called
glaucoma. There are two
types of glaucoma. One
is the open angle
glaucoma in which the flow
of fluid is
maintained however the
problem is in the
trabecular meshwork
that there is there
is a not enough
or not fast enough
drainage of this
fluid and then the
pressure increases
Now, the second
form of glaucoma is
the close-angle
glaucoma. Here,
mechanically, the iris
blocks the drainage
angle formed by
the cornea and iris
blocking the trabecular
meshwork. And
this is a medical
emergency. So it is
characterized by
redness in the eye,
nausea,
and headache associated
with blurred vision.
So the cornea
and the lens
focus the images
on the retina.
So focusing an image
requires refraction,
that is bending of
light, across one
or more interfaces
when there is a
change in the refractive
index. For example,
you can see this
in this glass of
water. The aqueous
and vitreous humor
refractive indices are
only slightly lower
than the refractive
index on the lens.
So the lens, although
we might think
that the lens is the
main optical element
in the eye, actually
most of the eye's
refractive ability
is at the air-water
interface at the
surface of the cornea.
So however, the lens can
provide some
accommodation.
So, the eye
accommodates for closed
vision by tightening
the ciliary
muscles, allowing the
pliable crystalline
cells to become
more rounded.
So, when the
ciliary muscles
contract, and here
we can see the
ciliary muscles
here in red,
the ciliary
muscles contract.
then the sonial
fibers which connect
the ciliary muscles
to the lens here.
These sonial fibers
relax and the lens
acquires a more rounded
shape. A more rounded
shape is going to allow
the light to bend more
so in this case this
adapt accommodate the
image for closed vision
so when the ciliary
muscles are relaxed
the these the sonal
fibers are more in
tension and the lens is
flat because you know
this is like a window
so there's not going
to be as much bending
of the light so when
the light comes from far
away objects is going
to focus on the retina
so this process is
called accommodation
so the other optical
element is the iris
which is the aperture
here that permits the
light to reach the
retina so the pupil
is the aperture in
the middle of the iris
so the pupil can
constrict can close and
that is under parasympathetic
control or the
pupil might dilate
and that is under
sympathetic control so
uh there are a different
set of muscles but
different control
So we have these
radially dilator muscles,
when they'll
contract, there's
going to be an
opening of the pupil.
There's also a
sphincter line where
the constrictor
muscle is located
around the pupil when
they'll contract.
This is going to be
like a sphincter and it
will close the pupil.
so smaller pupil has
some advantages in
that it produce larger
depth of field and
we'll explain that this
later but the con is
that there is less light
entering the eyes so
the aperture is smaller
they're going to be
less lighting less light
coming into the retina
however there is
some advantage to that
so this is a little
bit complicated so bear
with me so the how come
pupil contraction
provide depth of field
of view so here we have
a diagram of the uh
of the eye with a lens
with this end let's
imagine that there are
two objects x and y
here we have a large
pupil so in the length
the object x is in
focus so all the
light that comes out
from x is going to be
focused at the retina
however object y
is not it's not on
the focal plane it's
somewhere else and
what happened is you
can see by the geometry
when the pupil is
large there's a little
more light going
on but the focus is
going to be happening
away from the retina
but the actual passage
of this y object is
going to create a large
object y so we'll see
x in focus and y will
be completely out of
focus on blur however
However, but on
the other hand,
a lot of light
is coming in.
Now, if the
pupil is small,
X is in focus, so
that doesn't change.
However, why? Because
of the smaller
pupil, it's still going
to be out of focus,
but much less so.
So the size of the
object is going to
be smaller, so you
look more as in focus.
so smaller pupils
allow objects that
are not exactly
on the plane of focus
to appear focused
so we'll have a deeper
field of view with
a smaller pupil so this
is known we know this
from from from cameras
right so that the
the iris is played the
same role in photography
at the aperture
right so if they have
a large aperture only
the objects that are
on the on the focal
plane appear crisp and
the rest appear blur
however if we close
the aperture both the
plane the objects that
are on focus and the
objects that are away
from that plane of
focus are going to
appear more in focus or
more crisp however if
we close the aperture
there's going to be
also less light coming
in so and the brain
should be able to adapt
the aperture depending
on what do you
need so when we are
focusing on a nearby
object three things happen
in a reflex manner
so the convergence of
the two eyes because
yes because of geometry
you contract the
ciliary muscles so you
produce accumulation
of the lens and your
pupil contracts so
allowing larger depth of
the field of view and
allowing more of these
objects to appear in
focus and cortex and
cerebellum play an
important role in this
near reflex.
Let's now describe
the neural
processing
within the eye.
Here in the retina, we
have photoreceptors.
So these
photoreceptors are
going to respond
to light.
Then the information
from the photoreceptors
is going to travel
through the bipolar cells.
So here we have the
photoreceptors, then
we have the bipolar
cells, and the bipolar
cells are going to
provide input to the
ganglion cells. The
ganglion cells are going to
provide the output of
the eye to the brain.
There is also an internal
processing in the
retinue. There is
amacrine cells here,
and horizontal cells.
And you can see that
these cells are
going to be combining
information across multiple
photoreceptors, and
it's going to modify
the information flow.
Something that is
also important to
notice is that the
location of these
cells in the retina
is reversed to
what you will
suppose. So, actually,
the light has to cross
through the ganglion
cells, through the
microcell, bipolar
cell, horizontal cell,
to finally reach the
photoreceptor. So,
light goes this way,
but information flow
goes the other way.
It goes from the
photoreceptors
to the ganglion cells.
There are two types
of photoreceptors,
there are the rods
and the cones, and
this is actually a
descriptive name,
the rods are rod-like and
the cones are cone-like.
So these photoreceptors,
their characteristic
is that they have
very large membranes.
So the reason to
have large membranes,
it's allowed to
collect more light,
because the
sensitive elements in
these photoreceptor
cells are in
the membrane. So,
there are different
opzines in the
rods and cones.
Rhodopsine is in
the rods and the
cone pigments
are in the cones.
The opzines bind to
11-6 retinal. The
light is going to
isomerize the 11-6
retinal to all trans
-retinal that is
bound to the opzine.
The light-inducing
isomitization of
the retinal causes
a conformational
change in the opsin.
This activates
transducin, which
in turn activates
an enzyme,
phosphodiesterase, that
hydrolyzes cycle GMP.
And decreased
availability of cycle GMP
causes the cycle GMP
-gated cation channels to
close. And the cells
hyperpolarize. So that's
interesting that contrary
to other receptor
neurons, these
photoreceptors, you can
see that the membrane
potential becomes more
negative when they are
activated by light.
Now, also you notice
that the rods are larger
than the cones, so this
means that the rods
are going to be more
sensitive to light.
so you need less light
because there's more
membrane to activate
but you have better
resolution with the cones
we have a more smaller
but less sensitive
also notice that the
because of the cells
hyperpolarizing in response
to light photoreceptor
reduce their
neurotransmitter release
in response to light all
the rods are more
sensitive but they saturate
here is you can see
an electrical trace
of the response of rod
to different amounts
of light and you can
see that there is
saturation like the
level of light is
increasing but the
output of the rod is not
increasing that is
saturation in contrast
the cones there seem
to be less sensitive
right you can see
that the responses
are smaller but there
is no saturation so
and these roads
and cones play
different roles
in the retina
because of this
specialization of
the different
type of cell the
retina is not
uniform So here is a
fundoscopic view
of the left retina.
So you can see here
the optic disc.
So the optic disc
is where the optic
nerve is going to
be attaching to the
retina. You can see
that the arteries
and veins come from
the optic disc.
This optic disc has no
needle cones and rods.
So it's actually blind.
There is no light
sensitive cells here.
the opposite is can
be said about the phobia
so here in the phobia
you can see that there
is no blood vessels
there so there's no
it's only going to
have photoreceptor
there there is a high
concentration of cones
in the phobia so this is
the place where we
have the most accurate
vision remember the cones
are smaller and they
are sensitive for
color and there is also
high concentration of
rods outside the phobia
so which is interesting
is that the phobia
which is the highest
resolution area because
there are not many
rods there is not the
most sensitive part
So sometimes when you,
for example, are
looking at the night sky
and there is a very
dim star that you want
to look at, you might,
if you look directly
at it and put the image
on the phobia, you
won't be able to see
it. But if you move your
eyes slightly away,
then you're going to
put that image onto
parts of the retina that
have the rods, which
are more sensitive. And
then you'll be able
to see that dim star.
So we said that
near the edge of the
optic disc is a
circular portion of
the retina, about
5 millimeters in
diameter. That's called
the macula lutea.
the center of the
macula is a depression
called the phobia which
we talk about which
is particularly rich
in cons color vision
the central phobia
is specialized for
vision of the highest
acuity all the neurons
and capillaries are
present elsewhere and
the periphery you
have cons and roads so
you have black and
white and color vision
so uh well another
optical or another region
of the uh retina is
the optic papilla as
the optic papilla
optic nerve penetrates
the retinal layer and
leaves the eye and
the retinal blood
supply enters and exits
this creates the blind
spot in the retina the
blind spot is located
15 degrees temporarily
from the phobia so
that's in like in
visual space and we
are not aware of this
blind spot because the
nervous system fills
it in here is a
demonstration if you now
cover your left eye
and stare the plus in
the green square and now
move your head closer
to the screen and at
one point the circle
will disappear and
your brain will fill
it in with the with
yellow so you have put
at that point you have
put this circle into
the blind spot but
you we don't have an
conscious perception
of the blind spot
our brain is smart
enough to fill it
out based on the
surrounding images.
Now, remember what we
were talking about,
the flow of information
is in opposite
direction of the flow
of light. However,
having the light
travel to the ganglion
cells and to these other
parts of the retina
would be detrimental
for the phobia because
we want to have the
most accurate vision
there so there what
happens is there is a
higher density of cones
but there are no blood
vessels or other
cells in the light pad
so the phobia is the
place where the light
directly impinges onto
the photoreceptors
and that's where we
have our maximum equity
so what what's the
size of our phobia so
you extend your arm
in front of you and
now look at the size
of your thumbnail
that's the size of
your phobia that's
the size where you
have highest equity
but we are not aware
of that we have this
illusion that our
whole field of view
has high acuity but
that's not true what
happens is that we come
we always we are always
moving our eyes like
this famous picture
where when we look at
the face we have the
impression that we
are looking at this
face and we have high
acuity all over the face
but what's happening
if we look our eye
movement here we keep
moving our eyes around
on these saccades
and then we recreate
our brain creates this
higher resolution image
but that is an illusion
so that is mostly
make uh bring into
attention by conditions
like age-related
macular degeneration amd
amd causes damage to
the macula but spurs
most of the retina
so it's if you think
about it like extend
your arm think about that
and think about the
size of your thumbnail
you're saying okay
that that part of the
retina is damaged no
big deal however and
you are not blind but
you lose the ability
to see because the loss
of the central vision
in amd interfere
with simple everyday
tasks as to the ability
to see faces, to dry,
to read, write and
do close work such as
cooking or fixing
things around the house.
So although the affected
area of the retina
is pretty small, the
effect is quite large.
Now there are three
types of cones. The
cones are going to
provide us with the
uh color vision so
we have the uh s
cones we have uh the
m cones and the l
cones so uh small
s comes from small
medium and large so
here uh we are plotting
the uh we're seeing
the wavelength
longer and shorter
wavelengths so shorter
wavelengths are more
towards the violet
or and the longer
wavelengths above 600
nanometers are for the
red colors so if you
remember your quantum
mechanics you will
know that the longer
wavelength wavelengths
have less energy
the quanta of this
longer wavelength have
less energy so it's
actually kind of hard
to design detectors
that can uh to to to
have detectors that take
that low energy and
in fact you can see
that both all these even
the l cones that are
responsible for red
vision its peak absorption
is yellow green But
here in their tail,
they still respond to
red, and they are going
to be given the
perception of red colors.
So now looking at the
output cells of the
retina, they are the
ganglion cells. these
ganglion cells uh respond
to contrast so they
actually uh have centers
around structure so
they are more responsive
for example for a
little dot surrounded
dark dots surrounded by
light there are different
type of ganglion
cells the numerically
dominant class of small
ganglion cells are
sensitive to color and
form and they are large
ganglion cells that
are more sensitive to
movement and contrast.
Now we will look
at the visual
pathways underlying
visual perception.
So, visual fields
and retinal fields.
The visual field of
each eye is the region
of space that the
eye can see looking
straight ahead without
movement of the head.
So now you can look
straight, close one eye,
that is the visual
field of one
eye, close the
other eye, and now
that's the visual
field of that eye.
So the phobia of
each retina is going
to be aligned with
a point called the
fixation point in
the visual field.
Peripheral images
fall on the
nasal hemiretina.
So we have the
the two visual
fields right so
there's a left
half and a right
half. This is
the visual field
and now what happens
is that the peripheral
images fall on the
nasal hemiretina. So
here Now we are in
the retinal space, and
here you can see that
there is a cross.
There is a cross on where
the images are projected.
That's not a neural
effect. This is just an
optical effect.
Remember that we have
lenses, and the presence
of the lenses causes
the images that are
projected in the retina
to be inverted. So
this inversion that you
are seeing here is
produced by the optics.
so the end result is
that the peripheral
images are going
to be uh projected
into the nasal
hemiretina so the part of
the retina that's
close to the nose so
this is the periphery
here and here on the
nasal hemiretina so
now let's just to be
clear let's focus what
happened on the left
eye in the binocular
field which is the
part of the visual
field that has that
is seen by both eyes
images in the left
half of the visual
field fall on the nasal
hemiretina of the left
eye images present
in the right half
of the visual field
of the left
eye fall on the
temporal hemiretina
of the left eye
so let's
see what happens when
we are looking at
an object so let's
see let's imagine that
we're looking at this
arrow and here we
have our retinas right
and from the point
of view of the left
eye you can see how
this more peripheral
object is going to
be projected onto
the nasal hemiretina.
So now in the retina,
we have the ganglion
cell axons which travel
to the optic chiasm.
So there's going to be
partial decruciation
of the optic nerve
fibers into optic tracts
at the optic chiasm
that is going to permit
binocular vision. So
if you think about it,
you can see how this
part of the arrow is in
the temporal hemiretina
of this eye, but is
on the nasal hemiretina
of this other eye.
In order to
create a binocular
representation, we need
to bring together these
two images that are
on different eyes.
So what happens,
all fibers from the
nasal half of each
retina cross decussates
to the contralateral
optic tract.
So in that way,
the images from
both eyes of the
same part of the
visual field can
come together.
All fibers from the
temporal half of each
retina are going to
pass through the lateral
portion of the optic
chiasm without crossing
and entering the
ipsilateral optic tract.
So, in the optic chiasm,
anatomically, these
decusating fibers from
the nasal hemiretina
that are going to
be representing the
peripheral vision are
going to be in the middle.
so what happens is
that the um the optic
chiasm is on top of the
pituitary gland so a
tumor of the pituitary
gland will cause
pressure here on the
optic chiasm and what is
going to be mostly
affected is going to be
the nasal hemiretina
projections that are
going to correspond to
the peripheral visual
field so here is an
example where we can see
an MRI of a normal MRI
and you can see here
a patient that has a
pituitary adenoma so
you can see here the
optic chiasm and you
can see how the optic
chiasm is going to be
pressed here in the
center which is the part
where you have the
fiber decusation so in
that case the symptom
that you will get
from this pressure is
going to affect the
temporal field of view
of both eyes so you are
going to be having
peripheral vision loss.
After the optic chiasm,
most of the fibers
in the optic tract
make synapses
onto the lateral
geniculibody, the
LGN of the thalamus.
So you can see
that here in this
section of the brain,
you can see the
optic tract, the optic
chiasm. You can And
follow this, and this
is going to go into
the lateral genicloin
nucleus, the LGN.
Neurons in the LGN are
contacted by fibers
originated from one
eye and have monocular
receptive fields.
Layers 1, 4, and 6
are the most superior
ones received from
the contralateral eye,
and layers 2, 3, and
5 from the ipsilateral
eye. So there's a
separation in the LGM
depending on which
layer from which eye
that input came from.
There are also
magnocellular layers, one
and two, that respond
to contrast and
movement, large,
magno, large. And the
parvocellular layers,
parvo small, respond to
color and form.
So you have higher
resolution, lower
resolution areas in the LGM.
Now, you also have
the LGN. The thalamus
has to project to the
visual cortex. Now,
the visual cortex,
as you probably are
aware, is located in
the occipital lobe.
So, there is a geniculo
-calcarine tract which
goes from the LGN to
the primary visual
cortex, which borders
the calcarine sulcus.
So there is a
radiation, which are
the actions that go
from the LGN, and
these reactions
radiate in a broad
sheet around the
lateral ventricles.
There are two main
pathways for that to reach.
One part of the visual
field is going to
be traveling through
the Mayer's loop that
will correspond to the
superior visual field,
and that goes through
the temporal loop.
So, one way to remember
this is remember
in vision everything
is going to be
reversed, so the major
loop travels through
the temporal lobe, the
temporal lobe is more
inferior, so of
course that's going to
represent the superior
visual field. So,
if you have damage
to the temporal lobe,
then you might affect
the major lobe, and
you have the defect
that is called pie in
the sky, so where the
person is going to
complain of loss of
vision on the upper visual
field, contralateral
to the loss of field
of view. There is
also the upper optical
radiation that passes
under the parietal
lobe, and this is called
the inferior optical
field, and so you have
loss of the inferior
optical field that
might indicate that you
have damage in the
parietal lobe. So when
you have blockage of
the middle cerebral
artery and its branches,
it may affect the
major loop or the upper
optical radiation.
Individual fibers
carry information from
only one eye, so
damage here often
results in deficits
that are overlapping
but are not identical
in the two eyes.
Now, in the primary
visual cortex, the primary
visual cortex is
located in the occipital
lobe, as always in the
visual field, in the
visual, everything
is reversed, so the
inferior visual fields
of the inferior part of
the world project to
the cortex above the
calcadine sulcus. and
the superior visual
fields project to the
cortex below the sulcus.
Now the macula, the
fobial vision, is
represented more
posteriorly and peripheral
fields of view are
represented more
anteriorly. So the
blood supply to
this primary visual
cortex is provided
mostly by the posterior
cerebral artery.
So, now let's look at
the visual deficits
that appear, and
this might be a
little bit complicated,
but this is
something that you
will see a lot of
questions for boards,
so let's look at it.
So,
just a little bit of
language. Hemianopia
means loss of half
of visual field.
quadrant tenopia means
a loss of a quarter
of a visual field
and these visual
losses can be homonymous
where the visual
field losses are
similar for both eyes
they could be congruous
identical or non
-congruous overlapping
but not exactly the
same and heteronymous
means that the two
eyes have non
-overlapping field losses.
So here you have
the visual fields,
the retinal fields,
the deglutation of
the optic chiasms,
and then you have
the two tracks, the
two paths of the
geniculo-calcaline
track. You have the
mayor loop, or you
have the other path
that goes through
the parietal
loop. So if you
have damage to
the optic nerve,
you have total
loss of vision
in one eye in this case
for this example for
the right eye now if
you have damage to
the optic carcin as we
thought before now the
both nasal hemiretina's
vision is going to
be affected and peripheral
view is going to
be affected but this is
not symmetric because
it's highly unlikely
that the tumor or
whatever is pressing
against the carcin is
perfect so you are going
to have non-homonymous
bitemporal hemianopia
so it's loss of
the peripheral view now
when when and visual
defects can be grossly
divided if they
are anterior from
the optic eyes or
posterior so if they
are anterior from the
optic chiasm are
going to be by eye
the def is going the
the The deficit is
going to affect each
eye independently.
Once things go
posterior from the
optical essence,
the field is not
going to be per eye,
but the deficits
are going to be
per field of view.
So you have now on the
optic track a deficit.
You have contralateral
homonymous
hemianopia. So
you lose the field
of the optic
track is affected.
You lose vision coming
from both eyes. Remember
that there has been
an accusation, but
it's going to affect
the full field of view.
Now, if you have
now damage in the
temporal lobe, in the
mayor lobe, you'll
have the pie in
the sky disorder.
So you have superior
homonymous quadrant
anopia, right? So
the field of view,
the upper part of
which is coming
from both eyes, is
going to be lost.
Now, if the deficit is
localized to the
parietal log, you
have inferior homonymous
quadratenopia,
the pie in the
floor disorder.
If the whole
geniclocalcarine tract is
affected, you have
contralateral homonymous
hemianopia. So you
lose both the upper
and the lower filopio.
Now, if now, now
when we go to the
cortex, you have either
the inferior bank of
the calcarine fissure
is affected, then
you'll have superior
left homonymous
quadentinopia, and if
the superior bank of
the calcarine fissure
is affected, then the
field of view that
will be affected
will be the inferior.
now inferior left
inferior homonymous
quadrantenopia if
both banks of the
calcarine sulcus are
affected much larger
then you have
contralateral homonymous
hemianopia now you
can see that that
in the in the visual
cortex deficits
there is some there's
macular sparing,
which means that the
vision in the phobia,
the phobial vision, the
high resolution vision,
tends to be preserved.
So let's talk about
a little bit about
that macular sparing.
Macular sparing,
remember that the
entire visual cortex
is supplied by
the calcane artery,
which is a branch
of the posterior
cerebral artery.
The more caudal parts
of the visual cortex
tend to receive also
blood supply from
collateral branches
of the middle cerebral
artery so there are
two routes for blood
supply for the foveal
for for the foveal vision
one is coming from
the posterior cerebral
artery but there is
also from the middle
cerebral artery also
remember that the
phobia is very important
so there is an expand
representation in
cortex so the cortex
is going to assign a
very large area. Many,
many cells are going
to be representing
that folio because
it's that important. So
it is unlikely that
the damage or ******
is going to just block
the whole thing. So
that's why you have
that macular sparing.
And so the macular
sparing is clinically
important because it
permits to differentiate
medial cerebral
artery infarctation
that affects the
geniculocal calcaryng
tract, which there
won't be no macular
sparing, from posterior
cerebral artery
infarction, where
there will be macular
sparing. If there is
macular sparing, it
means that the cortex
is being affected.
Another important
feature about the visual
system is this condition
called papilledema.
So the optic nerve
is part of the
central nervous system
embryologically.
So the meningeal
coverings are
similar and continuous
to the other
areas of the central
nervous system.
So the sclera is
the continuation of
the dural sheet when
it's lying inside
by the arachnoid
and the pia mater.
The subarachnoid space
is continued with the
subarachnoid space
around the optic nerve.
So if there is elevated
intracranial pressure,
that elevated
intracranial pressure is
going to be
transmitted through the
optical nerve. So
there's going, and it's
going to be visible
in the fundoscopic
exam. So if there is
a compression of the
optic nerve, that
condition is called
papilidina. It's going
to be characterized
by the swelling
of the optic disc.
and so this is a non
-invasive tool that
might indicate elevated
intracranial version
using just a fundoscopy
we don't need to
make a spinal tap or
something like that
there so we have been
focusing mostly on
the path from the
eye to the cortex but
there are other
additional optic tract
branches there is a
superior colliculus where
we have head orientation
eye movement,
but this pad is more
important in
lower animals.
There are also
accessory optic
nuclei that are
important for
retinal image
stabilization.
And also the
hypothalamus, the
suprachiasmatic
nucleus, it's
related to our
circadian rhythms.
So there is input,
part of that circadian
rhythm is determined
by the time of day,
which we determine by
the amount of light so
photic input regulates
our circadian rhythm
so how is visual
information process in the
cortex visual information
is actually separated
into different
features so and this is
done in a distributed
manner so they are part
of the brain that respond
more to orientation
they are parts of the
cortex that respond
to color or respond
to depth or to motion
so each different part
is going to analyze
its its information
simultaneously and it is
thought that this this
is a much faster way
to analyze all parts
separately and integrate
it into a final image
and each column on
cortex responds to a
certain type of stimulus
so here we have a
vision a picture of the
brain so here the
occipital lobe where
we have our primary
visual cortex and there
are two paths leaving
the visual cortex
one is the dorsal
part which is called
also the wear pathway
which is going to
be there it's going
to be representing
mostly location and
motion And there is a
ventral pathway, the
watt pathway, which
is going to be related
to form and color.
So remember that there
were these magnocellular
and parvocellular
differences at the
level of the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
The magno were more
about movement, right?
And that separation
and the parvo were more
about detail and
color. So the parvo are
more related to the Watt
pathway and the Magnu
are more to the Wehr
pathway. So there's
a separation from the
LGN about these two
different parts of
the visual perception.
So we can have different
losses of visual
capabilities. So if we
damage the posterior
brain, that's going to
affect both the optic
radiation or the
striped cortex. visual
cortex so we'll have
full visual loss in some
aspect of our visual
field but however as
we go if the damage
occurs more advanced in
the what and where
pathway the deficits
are going to be more
specific which is kind
of interesting so one
one deficit that could
appear is motion
blindness so for example
we have a case 43 year
woman suffer bilateral
infarcts of lateral
parts of parietal
occipital on posterior
temporal lobes visual
fields color vision
depth perception and
rhythm were unaffected
however she still can
cells moving sounds
and feel moving on skin
but she is not
able to detect
visual motion so
that's a motion
that's a dorsal
stream lesion so
so on the powerpoint
you should
be able to see
a video but uh
people that have
motion blindness
it's actually kind of
dangerous for example
if they want to cross
the street they won't
see the cars moving but
they'll see a blurry
image not not blurry
image but it'll be
like jumping images so
there'll be car in one
position and they'll
try to cross but the
car is actually moving
but they don't perceive
that movement so it's
kind of dangerous
so there's also a color
blindness on prosapnoxia
so this example of a
man that has abrupt
onset of headache and
confusion one evening
he doesn't lose
consciousness but
subsequently remember
nothing that occurred during
the next 12 hours he
was taken home and
helped to bed and when
he awoke the next morning
he became aware of
several visual deficits
so there are some
visual field deficits
however he lost the
ability to
recognize colors
which is called
achromatopsia
and he also lost the
ability to
recognize faces
prosopgnosis so
this is not about
uh this is not the
where pathway this
is the what pathway
so this would
indicate lesions in
the ventral stream
The posterior
palatal cortex plays
an important role
for localization,
and there are
multiple association
areas for
multiple senses.
It's a processing center.
Damage to the left
side is usually
less frequent
and transient
compared to the
right side damage.
Right hemisphere is
dominant for spatial
attention. After left
hemisphere damage, the
right hemisphere can
direct attention to
both the contralateral
and ipsilateral side.
But after right
hemisphere damage, the
left hemisphere
can only manage to
attend to the
contralateral side. So the
left side of the
world is neglected.
So that condition is
called heavy neglect.
so imagine that you
are seeing a 50 year
patient in your office
he's accompanied by his
wife he had a right
-sided ****** last year
and is currently
undergoing physical therapy
to recover some of his
motor control for the
last now he has been
able to feed himself
his wife interjected
during your hmp stating
that for some reason
his plate of food looked
like this when he's
done so you can see that
the person is only
perceiving the right
side of the word and he
doesn't even perceive
the left side of the
word so these patients
uh uh you can ask them
to copy and up like a
clock and he's only
going to draw the right
side of the of the
house of the claw of the
flower So, this is
classically associated
with right posterior
parietal cortex lesions.
So, this is damage to the
processing of the image.
It's not the same as
hemianopia. It's just
that the subject
actually is ignoring the
existence of the left
part of the world.
Another interesting
condition is blindside,
where you have lesions
in the primary visual
cortex so the person
becomes cortically
blind so they cannot see
they cannot consciously
see however when
they are asked to
guess aspect of visual
stimulus they are
significantly better
than chance so the person
says no i cannot see
and then can you try to
uh put this letter to
this lot but i cannot
see well try and then
they'll do it right
so so they don't have
a conscious perception
but there are other
parts of the brain
that are not cortical
that are taking over
and permitted to do
some actions however we
are not conscious of
that so that'll be all
and thank you very
much for your attention